welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a labor
problem in california that could affect
the nation's economy independent
truckers have all but shut down the port
of oakland they're protesting a new
state law that resets how they work
including whether they're entitled to
job benefits oakland is a major hub in
world commerce and as jamie yukis
reports the concern is that the work
stoppage will threaten the already
strained supply chain
this is one of the 10 busiest ports in
the nation now it's silent
except on the outside where truckers
gathered for a fifth straight day
they've effectively shut down the port
of oakland protesting a new california
labor law that makes it harder for
independent drivers to operate i'm here
to support my family because we have a
bills to pay gladys hernandez says she's
been here every day and has no plans to
leave you don't want to turn labor union
and the corporate truck drivers against
you want them with you right oakland
police captain clay burch says he
understands the driver's frustration but
warns of unintended consequences the
shutdown is the latest in a long line of
west coast work stoppages that have
affected the supply chain and added to
inflation cargo here is mostly
agricultural
it's about the greater goods about the
consumer as well think about the end
game here what's not getting out what's
not getting in we're talking about
perishable goods food items things like
that right now this is limited to
oakland but there is concern the
protests could spread to southern
california where they are still
recovering after massive gridlock last
year what if people stop being
sympathetic to you because they start
seeing the grocery prices go up it's
okay no problem but i had to family to
support as these containers start to
pile up the ripple effect is significant
it's not just the protesting drivers
it's anyone at the dock who is loading
or offloading they're not getting paid
for cbs saturday morning jamie yukas
oakland